vi presento un maestro della
contaminazione di era un gigante della
contaminazione
[Musica]
dispiace parlare
sopra la questa musica di interromperla
e libertango di astor piazzolla
la versione per orchestra sinfonica
astor piazzola è stato un grande
musicista un grande compositore è un
grande ibridatore del tango perché sia
perché inserisce nel nella forma
originaria del tango degli strumenti che
in origine non erano previsti tra cui
anche la musica elettronica sia perché
ibrida la forma proprio musicale del
tango con altri generi musicali come il
jazz la fuga
e questo lo ha reso per molto tempo
osteggiato molto mal visto dai
contemporanei conterranei e soprattutto
dai sostenitori della purezza del tango
originario che vedevano in lui un
corruttore chiaramente del tango la
contaminazione è il filo conduttore di
questo mio intervento per contaminare
qualcosa bisogna metterlo in relazione
con qualcos'altro
quindi come dire che le relazioni sono
anche il filo conduttore di questo
intervento
noi ancora oggi sentiamo parlare di
reale in spesso in contrapposizione a
virtuale di offline in contrapposizione
a 1 online ma quando ci spostiamo ad
esempio con google maps in a piedi
oppure con i mezzi dove siamo
siamo online osiamo offline siamo in
entrambi questi luoghi
ammesso che siano tali e in nessuno cioè
difficile oggi tracciare una linea di
demarcazione tra questi due tra queste
due sfere tanto che il filosofo
dell'informazione luciano floridi
italiano insegna ad oxford
ha coniato il neologismo per definire
questa questo scenario
lui parla di onlive per dire appunto che
se ormai creata una online e offline
sono collassati non lo so l'altro
insomma si sono fusi questo fa sì che le
nostre esperienze oggi siano
estremamente complesse dire per certa
grazie anche in volute cioè quando noi
interagiamo con una organizzazione
un'azienda quindi quando cerchiamo ad
esempio un'informazione oppure quando
vogliamo fare un acquisto
seguiamo un percorso che è che somiglia
molto per certi versi al gioco della
campana al gioco dell'oca quindi un
percorso non predicibile non lineare
fatto di salti continui di passi falsi e
gli studi dicono che può arrivare a
durare giorni prima che noi
in certi casi prima che ne prendiamo una
decisione e in questo tragitto
noi facciamo se un uso sequenziale di
media i canali disposti a cavallo tra
fisico e digitale sia anche a volte un
uso simultaneo come la bambina di prima
che sta su due caselle un piede su non
viene sull'altra è frequente non solo
fra i più giovani ormai che cerchiamo un
informazione online su un prodotto
servizio poi però facciamo l'acquisto in
negozio oppure viceversa per prodotti
dove la componente tattile esperienziale
particolarmente importante andiamo in
negozio magari guardiamo misuriamo
investito poi però acquistiamo online
oppure ancora più complesso facciamo un
giro completo cioè partiamo dal web poi
ci trasferiamo in un negozio in un
ufficio poi ritorniamo sul web e magari
il percorso continua ancora ecco questo
schiude delle opportunità delle delle
sfide nuove ma anche delle opportunità
per la progettazione intendo
progettazione nel senso più ampio del
termine cioè come progettazione di
servizi o di esperienza
in tutti gli ambiti anche quello sociale
anche quello imprenditoriale
quindi non tanto l'azienda intesa come
azienda che produce un prodotto un
servizio per i clienti ma proprio
l'azienda in quanto tale in quanto
flussi informativi al suo interno in
quanto persone è un esempio in questo
senso c'è un esempio che sfrutta in
maniera efficace a mio avviso questo
scenario è quello del cooper museum di
new york un museo dedicato al design per
il quale che chiusa i vari contesti
dell'organizzazione fisici e digitali
non in isolamento l'uno dall'altro ma in
maniera complementare cioè ognuno è
concepito in modo da arricchire
l'esperienza dell'altro in maniera tale
che chi si muove da una casella
all'altra del del gioco della campana
che vedevamo prima non sperimenta una
frattura panzi sperimenta una continuità
per il cu per l'esperienza di visita non
comincia dentro il museo e non finisce
quando noi usciamo dal museo così come
molte altre esperienze
comincia prima e finisce dopo comincia
prima ad esempio quando noi
pianifichiamo la visita e quindi ecco
che il sito web del museo è concepito
fra le altre cose per permettere un di
costruirsi un itinerario su misura
scegliendo di percorrere le gli oggetti
della collezione o in base al tema
moltissimi temi anche in base al colore
in base anche ad altre suggestioni
questo percorso può essere poi
recuperato dentro il museo grazie
all'internet delle cose e con strumenti
come questa penna ad esempio si possono
fare molte cose non solo avere
informazioni sugli oggetti che si stanno
guardando
ma anche interagire con questi quindi ad
esempio acquisire i disegni dell'oggetto
e manipolare giocarci prendere
punti chiaramente non si tratta di
vedere la tecnologia semplicemente come
una feature in più che si aggiunge solo
per fare effetti speciali ma è qualcosa
che serve a garantire una continuità
come come dicevo prima tra i vari
contesti e mondi del tale varie facce
del museo è infatti di nuovo dopo la
visita io posso attraverso il sito web
ancora ripercorre ciò che ho fatto e
scaricarli tutto il materiale quindi si
crea una circolarità perfetta tra questi
diversi queste diverse sfere e questo fa
sì che da qualunque punto io comincio la
il mio itinerario posso comunque passare
all'altro senza sperimentare una
un'interruzione una frattura
questo dà un valore aggiunto non solo
per il pubblico che sicuramente vivere
un'esperienza più ricca ma anche per
l'organizzazione perché permette al ciò
che è stato concepito dall'alto dal
dall'esperto dal dal museo di venire
misurato sul comportamento effettivo del
pubblico che può essere monitorato in
tempo reale e quindi questo a sua volta
porre tra agire sul design cioè se io
voglio posso utilizzare questi feedback
per migliorare il design che è stato
concepito dall'alto quindi di nuovo
delle categorie che spesso abbiamo
considerato opposte quindi
l'organizzazione al pubblico il designer
e il cosiddetto utente vengono a
fondersi non sono più contrapposte ma
diventano parte di un circolo virtuoso
unico per raccontare tutto questo alla
triennale di architettura di lisbona del
2013 quindi non nemmeno recentissima
un'agenzia di architetti ha presentato
un cortometraggio perché meglio di tante
parole valgono le immagini e questo film
è ambientato in india
la città indiana del prossimo futuro e
vede come protagonisti dei bambini che
giocano a nascondino su pancho paia il
nome indiano del nascondino giocando a
nascondino questi bambini a che erano la
città sa che erano in senso buono il
concetto di hecking e quello centrale
del del filmato ne vediamo un frammento
[Musica]
la rete questa bambina interagisce con
gli spazi come non sia abituato a fare
con le interfacce gestuali e così
facendo per nascondersi insieme al
compagno accede alla città nascosta cioè
a uno strato diciamo non visibile della
città perché l'idea portante di questo
video è che la città
ecco rete dicono qui nessuno ci troverà
perché solo la città può vedersi l'idea
portante dicevo anche la città è un
luogo e un impasto di fisico e digitale
di atomi ebit per cui c'è questo nucleo
diremmo con un linguaggio informatico
c'è un core che il cuore che è questa
che vediamo la città antica selvaggia
vergine su cui è stato costruito un
rivestimento un'interfaccia che quella
che vedevamo prima delle case celesti e
che si può modellare con la quale si può
interagire chiaramente qui c'è un
iperbole c'è un esagerazione pepper all
idea che si vuole veicolare è proprio
questa dello spazio modellabile di un
luogo che si che si adatta e ho
riportato questa queste parole di
giuliana bruno perché mi sembrano molto
efficaci
lei parla di luoghi come c'era la cera
richiamo a due aspetti fondamentali 1
che lacera e plasmabile facilmente 2
ascrivibile con la cera si facevano le
tavolette su cui si scriveva il
palinsesto luogo diventa scrivibile le
nostre storie le nostre interazioni con
il luogo non sono più destinate volendo
è a evaporare
come sempre le nostre interazioni
produce producono storie ma le possiamo
in qualche modo capitalizzare e
utilizzare richiamare utilizzare per
migliorare quello che test che è fatto
dagli architetti dal designer da chi sia
dall'alto
tra l'altro giuliana bruna l'autrice di
bellissimi libri che intersecano arti
visive cinema architettura e mi piaceva
riportarla proprio perché credo che
questo approccio ibrido sia necessario
per comprendere una realtà che ha
altrettanto ibrida è complessa e per la
quale le categorie tradizionali
altrimenti non non ci aiutano da sole
quindi in conclusione oggi il design sta
evolvendo da design di oggetti cioè del
degli artefatti che hanno dei chiari con
fini che sono come questa scatola cioè
definiti chiusi che noi possiamo
utilizzare così
come sono verso design di sistemi che
invece è una relazione tra le scatole e
nel sistema quello che conta sono
proprio le relazioni tra gli elementi
più che gli elementi stessi
quindi l'invito è a focalizzare il
design a cogliere questa opportunità
vedere nella progettazione non tanto una
fabbricazione di oggetti materiali ma
più una abilitazione di relazioni tra
elementi che anche che già esistono per
elementi intendo tutto luoghi persone
servizi prodotti quindi in definitiva
d'ora in avanti quando pensiamo a un
progetto alla progettazione proviamo a
pensarla per orchestra come piazzolla e
per un'orchestra ibrida perché più sono
apparentemente lontani gli elementi
dell'orchestra in senso culturale più è
probabile che che questa produca una
effettiva innovazione grazie
[Applauso]